[Music]
hey welcome every damn day we're gonna
talk about Nicki Minaj's
sexual preferences the next Bachelor but
first check out this axe explosion this
is from Facebook user Becca Page in
Texas a semi truck carrying Axe body
spray exploded at 4:00 a.m. on the
interstate fortunately no one was
injured so we're allowed to laugh at
this it caused a huge fire they had to
shut down the interstate for eight hours
show that next clip there's cans
everywhere they were exploding all over
the place because when an aerosol can
gets heated up yeah gonna explode loads
it caused so much damage that they're
gonna have to replace the interstate
it's back to horse and buggies because
do we think that axe is gonna have
drivers fine yeah he smells insane do we
think axe is gonna release a new body
spray now named after what this yeah
fire fire tires I like dumps on this as
if it's not like a million dollar yeah
tens of millions whatever axe is the guy
fieri of sense to me
you got a Mentos to a face week and we
haven't lost a step let's all on
really bad like instead of like sucking
at a mentos he just chew right into it
right or like you're the type of guy
when you see a problem you're gonna have
a clever solution with your friends
remember rolling on the bench
you look like someone who has the
complexion of someone who only for your
body all right I want to talk about
something else now we're done with the
axe yes I had all kinds of great things
to talk about it great product I've used
it before it does a service like like
confuse teens or just covering up their
body smells so we don't have to smell
down we just smell like mine cool woods
I think it's good it does remind me of
like middle school when I saw you know
it's like different scents bring you
back different time when I smell acts
I'm like yeah gym class middle school
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sound off in the comments if you think
Hannah should be times sex what else are
we talking about today
pull that up Nicki Minaj was on the
season premiere of and she said that
using the innuendo of exercise she
implied that she has to have a man who's
able to have intercourse three times a
night she says it needs to be an hour
and a half in between each time she's
yeah and she was she wants a sandwich
after her no foreplay no worked or she's
like I'm fine with it but let's get it
over with that seems like a terrible
like YouTube challenge like I have 3x X
3 times yeah Howie just sandwich an hour
and a half yet to be back at it actually
we should do that let's start it Minaj
sex challenge well I need someone to
have sex with I don't think she would be
willing to do this for the camera oh
yeah really hydrates hey
middle-schoolers make sure you pee I'm
talking about that but you got it is
that for men too
our story I want to talk about The
Bachelor just announced their new
candidate is that what they call I don't
know too much about this Natasha what
I'm just gonna catch everyone up real
quick the fans are not excited about all
those producers love him cuz you know
he's a pro former pro football player
he's a virgin I've got a charity he
loves dogs
what could be the problem right but
everyone's like he's so vanilla get him
out of here
I like when they don't like feel like
they're fame-seeking and they really
like want to find love that's what I
like that's like the kind of psychos I
can really get behind yeah you have
famously tried out I guess I
bachelor-man try it out for the bathroom
it was an audition and I didn't get it
but you got I did get far and the
guy was like you're a character and I
think I don't think that's a compliment
thank you said they lock you in the
house you can't read books you can't
read magazines you have no ax I won't be
a problem with you and they just get you
to drink a lot so that you cause drama
which I get for the show I decided not
to be honest
I mean they really wanted me but I just
like no I think I'm gonna you know if I
love the normal old-fashioned way and
drunken following in strangers like
debating who this guy should lose is not
too crazy Amir is not married you can do
is throw a reality TV show and he just
needs to lose it's not I've never heard
that phrase something that would happen
in an axe explosion so last week we
asked our YouTube community what's the
most daring thing you've ever done and
Javier Fernandez said earlier today I
got myself surrounded by 20 horses some
stomping a pony I was in the danger zone
truly I feel like this is appellate I
guess what I wanted to say is I'm Javier
Fernandez thanks for leaving comments
we're gonna do something different right
now this is attention hacks and today's
theme is back to school rather than
start a conversation be the conversation
these are tips I've done I've seen
you're welcome number one demand a
standing desk look we all know sitting
is bad for our backs and studies have
shown that too much sitting actually
leads to earlier deaths but that's
irrelevant
the real reason to demand a standing
desk is to establish dominance in the
room force people to look up to you
number two question everything some
answers are concrete like math or when
she asks does this make me look fat
keep your class ten minutes over by
asking irrelevant questions yes the
square root of 64 is 8 but our
we all just living in a computer
simulation don't just question your
teachers education make them question if
they even want to be a teacher number
three
snack time a lot of people will tell you
that a tuna fish sandwich is
inappropriate for 9 a.m. or that
family-style fettuccine alfredo is too
heavy for a snack do you know how many
people have asked me if I've been raised
by wolves a growing number
[Music]
number four body spray for a full day
stank make sure you douse yourself and
whatever body spray is on sale Walmart
really spray it on thick that way when
people enter room 10 minutes after you
left people will know Steven was here
number five start rumors the easiest
rumor is sleeping with a teacher but of
course don't actually sleep with a
teacher because they make $52,000 a year
and you are better than that but it is
okay just to tell people you slept with
the meanest teacher on campus they get
canned and you get a local front page
headline this is attention hacks and
join being the most popular kid in
school called beauty in the gate see if
I was a bitch oh gosh well I don't
[Laughter]
she was consider your own feelings in
front of other people you guys still in
contact at all or no she after the show
and did she left me a death threat
voicemail no why typically said I'm
gonna bomb your house
[Music]